joining me now Missouri Senator Josh
Hawley Senator the White House wants to
put you in a box if you want to send
money to the people of Maui you also
have to vote to send money to support
the war in Ukraine so what's your move
my move is to say that the only nation
building we ought to be doing Laura is
building this nation and I can't believe
that it's so hard for the White House
when asked about are we going to first
support our citizens who are in the
midst of a natural disaster and have all
these needs or first prioritize the
citizens of some other country they
can't just say America why is it so hard
why is it the answer oh yeah of course
we're going to start with Americans
because this is the United States of
America they seem to forget who they're
serving who they have been elected to
serve listen this is not hard if we
should be prioritizing Americans first
we should be rebuilding this nation and
we should not be engaged in this wild
nation building Endeavors overseas like
Ukraine like Afghanistan like Iraq these
people have learned nothing
well George Will argues that it's a
matter of principle conservatives should
be supporting Ukraine that people like
you or I who think we're spending way
too much money that we're just doing
that because Biden's for it
and you say
I I say I don't understand what the
principle is that he's talking about is
the principled neoconservatism where
we're supposed to transform every
country into the image of the United
States and be the world's policeman I
think that seems to be what these people
think with the neoconservatives think I
I just take a different view my view is
is that we're supposed to be defending
the United States of America my view is
we're supposed to be putting American
jobs and American workers and American
Prosperity first that ought to be our
number one goal our number one priority
but that's just not how these neocons or
the liberal globalists it's not how they
see things the Lord they've been dead
wrong about this for decades they learn
nothing from Iraq nothing from
Afghanistan now they're doing it all
over again in Ukraine and uh Senator
Mitch McConnell who's been the subject
himself of such uh controversy regarding
his freezing moments and his health he
got his Focus back yesterday on the
senate floor watch
President Biden has not been as decisive
as many of us would have preferred our
systems is being used to good effect
and how additional Appropriations are
critical for our defense industrial base
and competition with China is certainly
not the time to go wobbly
so draining our own munition stockpile
he's talking about Ukraine there
bankrupting ourselves
that's wait a second we're going wobbly
unless again you're all in Ukraine
regardless of the fact that it looks
like this offensive did not go well and
it still is not measurably showing
success at least Lincoln couldn't really
cite success he was talking around the
issue
well and now I'm I'm intrigued to learn
that if you support funding for Ukraine
you're actually supporting funding for
China I thought the argument was are you
going to send more billions of dollars
to Ukraine and now we're told oh it's
really going to China no it's not just
be honest let's be honest the arms and
Munitions that are going to Ukraine are
being spent and used in Ukraine not in
China and by the way we have no idea
what they're being used for in Ukraine
because we don't have a watchdog that is
tracking the money we don't know what
the money is going for they don't want
to know and that's why we shouldn't be
saying they don't want to know that's
exactly right they don't want to know
because we we don't that's not going to
look good for them Senator at 15 seconds
McConnell stays in his leader through
the end of 2024 how does that affect
Republicans chances are you concerned
yeah I am concerned I get asked about it
constantly I understand why people are
concerned about it I'm concerned about
it listen Laura I'll be honest with you
I didn't vote for Mitch McConnell for
leader he is not my choice to be a
leader and so I think we need to change
I've said that for months all right
Senator thank you so much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else